[Music]
marcy is in seattle washington hey marcy
welcome to the ramsay show
um hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um i have a question about long-term
care insurance
um my husband and i purchased policies a
few months ago
to avoid a
state
run
program that we thought was going to be
implemented as of january 1st
um that has since been delayed until at
least april of this year but it's
looking like it's going to be pushed out
even further like till july of 2023
so we're wondering if we should keep the
policies that we have
um they are not
um the best
uh long-term care insurance policy that
we probably probably could have gotten
you just wanted something to keep your
communist government from taxing you
exactly thank you
yes the state of washington has lost its
freaking mind
yeah
it's it was a ridiculous um act and
there's so many flaws in it and that's
why there's all these bills being
proposed now to try and delay it and fix
some of the
flaws i wish somebody put it in front of
the supreme court and just stomp on it
but uh but in the meantime we real
people out here have to deal with this
crap so i i wouldn't drop it if you're
gonna turn around buy it again in april
but if you don't have to buy it until
june of 23 then yes i would drop it so i
guess i'm probably tapping the brakes
and just watch see what happens if if
they kick it in in april you got to turn
on bite again right
uh yes yeah to avoid it yeah that's it's
a lot of trouble and so i'd probably
just sit on it for a month or two here
and then if they do kick the can on down
the road to june i'd drop it
how old are you okay
um my i myself i'm 49 and my husband's
54. but they're required by state law to
carry it now if they don't they get a
tax
correct regardless of age what are you
paying every month have you kind of
shopped this around to at least make
sure that you're yeah you're getting a
good deal
yeah we well
initially we didn't because in the there
was sort of a frenzy of people trying to
get policies in place so we just grabbed
whatever we could but we're paying for
combined my husband and i um about 200 a
month for our policy the state tax would
would be about half of that
um but
for
its garbage coverage
and um and then we i did actually um a
couple of weeks ago speak to one of your
elps for that specializes in long-term
care
uh insurance policies um and he said for
for about the same prices that we're
paying right now for a universal life
policy with a a long-term care writer he
could
get us a policy i'm sorry you said one
of my elps told you that no no no no i
didn't think so he could he could um
offer us a better policy
so one that fits within you know your
guidelines and everything not a
universal life policy but that would be
a similar cost basically equivalent to
what we're paying right now
well if you would rather change any way
then you could drop this way till april
figure it out or wait the following june
and figure it out and go to the one
you're changing to if you're going to
change any way that changes the answer
so it sounds like you bought the
universal life one and you do need to
drop that so yeah go ahead and drop it
now and then in april you if you have to
rebuy
to avoid the tax uh you can do that
again how many states require that one
oh one okay she lucked out by living so
far well i mean
they're just
complete
bonkers yeah i mean it's just you you
pass a law that if you don't carry
long-term care insurance you have to pay
a tax the equivalent of the cost of
long-term care insurance because the
state is going to have to pay
part of medicaid if you go into the
nursing home and it's just straight-up
socialism i mean it's just classic
uh but this is the reason people are
running out of some of these states is
their taxation and their and their
social policies are both just right
people are leaving by the
literally by the truckloads
so we're leaving the coast yeah it's um
they're coming to tennessee well yeah
yeah
the the latest one i saw was please
don't be a missionary just be a refugee
that's good meaning don't bring your
stupid vote with you if you come
so um
i've tried to get the tennessee state
legislature to pass a law that if you
move here from california you can't vote
for two years or until you've been
through indoctrination on what what
potentially running an economy looks
like but um
but they haven't picked me up on that
haven't uh responded to your email yeah
it's not not answered me on that one so
can you imagine why i think it went to
spam yeah yeah it went to that uh i'm in
that other file the special folder for
you the special folder for dave that's
it